[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen while I got
introduced let me introduce my guest
today Anthony pompliano a round of
applause please
[Applause]
pomp I think we took the best seats in
the House the nicest lighting we're
gonna have a little bit of fun today
um
let's start off with the obvious of kind
of where the state of the industry is
what just happened we had a wild run in
terms of the industry's growth or what
I've referred to as a phase that we've
gone through and we're kind of in this
potential phase change between a couple
of years two and a half years of growth
and potentially in another but
give us a recap what just happened in
the last two years yeah I think that um
there's really two things right on the
way up uh we saw the promise we saw the
excitement we saw uh immense high
quality Talent come into the space a lot
of that was fueled frankly uh by people
uh half running to something so people
saying this is a really interesting
technology this is a really big Economic
Opportunity either for economies or for
themselves individually but also it was
fueled by people running away from
something people were running from
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
they were running from a financial
system that they don't trust they were
running from kind of a centralized
system that very obviously is not
working for them and so when you get
people both running to something and
running away from something it could be
quite powerful as we saw
um and you know there's a lot of folks
who are critics of Bitcoin or the
broader kind of crypto industry who will
point and say I told you so right and
they'll say look look at all of these
idiots look what happened all the prices
fell everything was worthless all that
kind of stuff and even in Bitcoin terms
you know things down 75 percent compared
to the US dollar but what you have to
remember is that everything is down
right the Federal Reserve went from a
loose monetary policy to a tighter
Financial condition uh kind of stands
and they specifically used a phrase we
are going to destroy demand or like I
don't know about you guys but like they
were pretty [__] successful doing
that
and so obviously they're trying to get
inflation under control which is
important for them to do for a whole
bunch of reasons that are that are
pretty self-explanatory
um
but when you look at this industry
things are down significantly but if you
look at the stock market some of the
stock indexes are down 20 30 percent
there's individual stocks that many of
you would recognize things like Shopify
or doordash open uh door Etc that are
down 75 80 90 percent
there's not a lot of people who are
sitting here saying like Shopify is over
man I don't think anyone's going to use
that company anymore now again was it
overvalued is it correctly valued now
could it be undervalued that's where the
debate will happen but I think we just
have to remember that like a lot of kind
of the change over the last 12 months
was not necessarily because things
changed uh inside of Industries inside
of specific companies as much as it was
a macro change
um so I think that's like one big thing
and the second thing is look at all of
you here right uh I don't see any of you
leaving if you look at on-chain data
something like Bitcoin uh 67 percent of
Bitcoin in circulation has not moved in
the last 12 months
67 it's all-time high never before in
bitcoin's history has it been that high
and why is that important well if you go
back to 2017 2018 2017 Bitcoin hit a 20
000 High all-time high and it dropped 85
percent in that bear market and Stanley
drucken Miller who's a very well
respected Wall Street investors
compounded it about 30 percent over you
know almost 30 years uh he and Paul
Tudor Jones got on the phone in 2018 and
they said hey
these crazy ass kids
on the internet
have held this asset and it's gone down
85 percent
and what they found fascinating was
approximately 85 percent of people who
had held it at 20 000 still held it at
three
so they were like if they're not going
to sell it after an 85 drop they're
probably not going to sell and so that's
what convinced them to go ahead and
start looking at it more seriously and
so when you start to add up these data
points I think you have to separate out
um kind of the the critical view uh you
have to separate out price they have to
separate out fundamentals it's really
hard to do there's a lot of you right
now who get up in the morning and you
probably look at your portfolios or even
look at companies you work at or that
you're running you're like man this [__]
sucks
just remember that like this too shall
pass and I think the longer that you've
been around the more that you kind of
realize like now is actually the best
time because this is where a lot of the
opportunities will be captured and and
so speaking on bitcoin so 67 you said
hasn't moved what is bitcoin's role
if we look at the next two years we look
at the next five years what is its role
in the industry of web 3 but also in uh
the institutional side of things what
what role will it play going forward
yeah you have to remember uh Bitcoin is
the largest asset obviously uh in the
industry
um it's the one that has the longest
time frame or kind of existence uh it's
the most liquid but also it has the most
brand awareness right and so when you
add these things up what you have to
think about is
Bitcoin is the entry point for most
people now there was some people now are
starting to come in through nfts or
other types of things but when you look
at Bitcoin there was a study done I
think it was by grayscale that said 87
of bitcoiners hold some other asset
whether that's a stable coin whether
that's an nft or whatever and so what
that tells me is that most people in
this industry have a high degree of
confidence that Bitcoin will be around
in the future and they're also excited
about other things now whether the other
things they're excited about work or not
the free market will decide but if you
get the people who are in the industry
believe that Bitcoin is uh as a young
kid told me once a boomer coin right and
I was like what do you mean he's like
he's like that's not fun that's not
exciting that's not going to go up that
much like that's Boomer coin okay but
like actually in some way like that's a
huge Advantage because when the
institutions show up they don't want to
press as far out on the Innovation uh
kind of curve as possible they don't
want to take on as much risk as possible
bitcoin's compound annual growth rate is
you know depending on the day and price
sits somewhere between like 75 and 150
percent during Bull and bearish Cycles
now
name another asset that's done that for
a decade the compound annual growth rate
of that asset is off the charts and so
if a hedge fund on Wall Street had
simply just bought Bitcoin and sat on
their hands for a decade they've been
the best performing hedge fund
so when you see that what you realize is
that institutions want to come into the
space and what they're going to look for
is actually safety right it's a little
different a lot of individuals that come
into this space they're looking for risk
how do I take as much risk as possible
and they got to kind of touch the stove
a couple times and they realize ah maybe
I don't take as much risk as possible
they want to find you know something
else but institutions don't think that
way they're not thinking how high can
this stuff go what they're thinking
about is what risks do I need to
underwrite how do I allocate to the
space and then how do I protect against
that downside risk and I think that's
why Bitcoin continues to be an asset
where the institutions look first you've
got brand awareness you got safety you
got a long time Horizon and ultimately I
think it's a positive for whatever part
of the industry you're interested in to
get people involved so would you say
that this is kind of that institutional
moment for both institutions and also
again web3 that we're going to start to
see more institutions get active in this
industry we talk to a lot of of
traditional finance companies yesterday
talked a lot about out the industry and
why they've gotten in certain ways but
in your opinion is this that moment that
institutions will really start to begin
to grow their portfolio start to
diversify start to look at asset
allocations around digital assets yeah I
mean this whole meme of like the
institutions are coming is wrong like
they're already here they've been here
right in 2018 uh some of my partners and
I we raised capital from public Pension
funds from Hospital Systems endowments
um you know foundations uh all kinds of
these different institutional type
investors and now they were very
forward-thinking at the time right and
they kind of saw what the opportunity
was but if you fast forward that was
2018 four years later Fidelity yesterday
just announced trading of Bitcoin and
ethereum I think yep right
you're one one person was excited one
person all right so like if Fidelity
does that well guess what every other
asset manager is going to have to do
that right right and one of the secrets
is that back in the 90s uh not that many
people in here probably remember that
but there's a couple I see that might
um every company was a business and then
there was this kind of corner known as
the internet companies and it was really
cool and sexy to start an Internet
company and people will tell the story
that they left their corporate job to go
join an internet company and their
parents or their grandparents or their
family friend was like don't do this
you're going to ruin your career right
today when someone's like I run a
business no one's like man I bet you
that they're using rotary phones and
paper
oh of course they use the internet so we
don't think of internet companies
anymore in some way if if you met
somebody and they said I run an internet
company
you'd probably be like that's a weird
way to describe a business right so
every company is an internet company the
same thing is starting to happen with a
lot of these Technologies so what you
can see is Google Facebook Amazon right
all of these large tech companies
they're all doing stuff in the space
some of it'll work some of it won't but
they have dedicated teams to make this
work in the financial sector you see JP
Morgan Fidelity and a number of other
organizations they're doing the same
thing and then the other piece is every
single Services firm go talk to
accounting firms talk to law firms all
of them are now dealing with these
assets because they're saying our
clients have them yes and so when you
start to kind of just do a a look
through if you will of the economy this
technology is touching every single
sector in the economy every single
vertical and the reason why that's
important is because we have a growth
problem in America
our GDP growth cannot grow at a pace
that is necessary for us to be able to
pay the 30 trillion dollars of debt we
are in bad shape so what do they do they
keep raising the debt ceiling taking on
more debt it's like taking out a second
credit card to pay off your first credit
card is do that over and over and over
again and so one of the promises of this
entire sector is that we can actually
use new technology and Innovation to
drive economic growth and if we can bend
GDP growth from two percent to three to
four to five percent all of a sudden we
start to make a dent in that debt to GDP
ratio and so what is the most
fascinating part is that is actually
part of the historical Trend many people
don't realize this but if you go back in
history economic growth of economies was
like near zero right it would literally
take centuries to Dublin economy we now
double economies somewhere between 20 to
30 years so every 20 or 30 years
economies are doubling in size well what
happens if we can cut that down to every
10 years can we get it to every five
years that's the type of stuff that
becomes really interesting because this
is the fastest growing sector in the
economy and if politicians and
corporations can embrace it I think that
that'll end up serving really well for
both the United States and other
countries around the world and speaking
of pace so individuals like yourself and
I we pay attention this industry second
by second we see all this stuff that's
happening but many institutions for
instance can't keep up that's part of
the reason why we're here today at Miami
web3 is to help that education so we
look at what just happened last week
what just happened two weeks ago what
just happened a month ago what just
happened in the last six months a lot of
changes that for most institutions are
thinking
what's going on what is happening and
why should I participate more so
in a in a fair question what happened in
the Legacy Financial system for the last
12 months exactly exactly well and I
think that's a good reference point
because
you've got 2008 we had what 2013 2014
we've had these various cycles of
massive change but for web 3 as an
industry we had some wild changes in the
last six months and kind of what
happened in a summary in your words how
did this happen how did we get here and
how do we get to this point now where
we're looking
at this new change the most cynical view
is that we had a bunch of young people
with no historical context who recreated
many of the problems that the Legacy
Financial system has experienced over
the last 40 years and has worked through
and created solutions to right I mean at
the end of the day what was it it was
greed it was leverage and it was bad
business
okay uh that sounds like the story of
Wall Street right like that is literally
if you go through the the decades
um now again that doesn't feel good uh
it doesn't mean that we should embrace
that or somehow look at that as like a
positive but understanding that a lot of
the problems in this industry were from
bad decision making leverage and greed
okay uh that doesn't mean that uh you
know technology doesn't work that
doesn't mean people aren't going to
adopt the assets instead what it means
is that actually this is the freest
Market that any economy in the world can
interact with and you know I'm biased I
believe the free market is the single
best referee
um but what we've seen is that in the
Legacy Financial system there's a lot of
problems there's a lot of zombie
companies there's a lot of these issues
that don't get kind of corrected because
there's no self-correcting free market
mechanism we get intervention from
central banks we get all sorts of
manipulation of the stock market in
terms of hours of operation circuit
breakers things like that but in this
industry like
the crypto industry flushed out FTX
right right it was someone leaked the
balance sheet of a hedge fund in the
industry to a reporter in the industry
who reported on it and then Market
participants essentially put enough
pressure via free market mechanisms to
then Expose and ultimately bankrupt the
company and there's a lot of people
who've got hurt by that it's really bad
but at the same time that's what happens
in down Cycles as bad businesses get
washed out right and sometimes it's
because there's actually uh potentially
nefarious activities that are going on
other times it's because there's just
bad businesses and they don't have the
ability to sustain but in down Cycles
both in Legacy Financial system and here
what's supposed to happen is that the
bad businesses get washed out that
Capital gets reallocated to the good
opportunities and then you're able to
build on that Foundation moving forward
what we have seen in the Legacy
Financial system is that's not what
happens how many people in here remember
in 2020 when the airlines were like oh
[__] it this is bad and instead of going
to the debt or Equity Market they
literally ran to the government and was
like just give us free money
well why did they do that it's because
the government was the sucker in the
room right no one in the free market was
willing to give the airlines the deal
that the government gave them it was the
best deal on the table was from the
government
and so when you start to recognize that
okay that is not a free market system it
then begs the question can you correct
it can you push it back towards the free
market kind of uh mechanism or are
people going to opt out and go
participate in a free market and I tend
to think that most people will just
simply kind of uh mobilize themselves
and end up in the most free market that
they can find and do you think that
we'll have this this similar moment to
what we had in 2001 2002 and also in
eight 2008 and 2009 we also saw a lot of
M A activity where institutions large
corporations saw companies saw
technology scooped it up integrated it
which led to the next
large applications large services and
large developments with web3 it's been a
lot of the problems for many
institutions corporations
they may not have the talent to develop
it they have Legacy systems still
running from the 70s and also just maybe
not understand it do you think we're in
that moment where we're going to see a
lot of M A and A lot of growth from the
institutional side on applications I
talked to a lot of Corporations and I
always ask them why is the 25 year old
who's super excited about you know
Bitcoin or any other technology or
whatever why are they going to come work
at your company versus start their own
why are they going to come work at your
company versus go join you know the next
hot startup and many of them don't have
a good answer right and so they do have
brand awareness they do have really big
teams and a lot of resources that they
can use and they have capital and so to
your point I think that a lot of them
say okay we need to be a player here
let's wield the the tools or the weapons
that we have to our advantage and
usually what they reside on is capital
and so whether that's through
Acquisitions whether that is paying
insane salaries uh you know giving very
large Equity packages
um that that's really one of the biggest
tools they have and I think they'll
continue to use it so we look at the
next 12 months we're only a few weeks
away from the end of the year which is
wild let's just take a moment to
appreciate that but we look at still
2019 it feels like it does it does it
does and now we're headed into 23 we
just we lost a few years they are now
looking at 23
where are you placing your bets what
categories are you excited about within
the industry or maybe other Technologies
as you look at the 12 months ahead of us
as both an investor and also as a
technologist what are you excited about
yeah
um I'll caveat this with like I'm super
risk-averse which sounds insane to most
of the Wall Street folks
um but I've always said that uh Bitcoin
in my opinion is the most risky thing
that is in the portfolio of a
traditional investor they look at it as
kind of a one or two percent allocation
hey maybe the crazy people on the
internet are right and like I don't want
to miss out and I kind of want to have
fun with my friends if it goes up uh but
if I lose it oh I'm not really going to
be that mad it's one percent whatever
when you look in the crypto industry
more broadly most of the people who are
working on nfts or some smart contract
stuff or whatever they'll point at
Bitcoin and Boomer coin right like uh
it's like whatever uh it's like that's
actually kind of where I want to live is
uh I want to be taking more risk than
the really conservative people but I
want to be taking less risk than the
really risky people
um and so pretty much for me I just buy
Bitcoin
um and then on top of that I do a lot of
private investing and so if you think of
kind of the the highest asymmetry
um and kind of the best risk reward in
my opinion this is to continue to invest
in in companies where usually they are
somewhat insulated from uh price
movements of individual assets and it's
more so kind of a macro bet as long as
this industry survives these companies
are run by good Founders
um and uh and they're kind of built in a
sustainable way then nothing will be
successful and last question we're
sitting here in the great City of Miami
who's welcomed us welcomed our
confidence all of us have traveled here
to to spend time together in my time
here I've been asked a similar question
that we spoke about backstage time and
time again is with the recent events in
the industry the last few weeks the last
few months
can Miami still be Miami can Miami still
be the Hub of web 3 and will the city be
reshaped because the industry went
through some changes as well
no I mean like if you think about it how
many of you came here and you had to
take off a winter coat when you got off
the plane because you came for somewhere
that was cold I hate the cold I'm not
leaving right how many of you live in a
state that when you go to work January
through June you're working for the
government
right because you pay a tax rate where
if you're in the top tax brackets over
50 percent
like you start to put this stuff
together it's the weather it's the taxes
it's all these things but I don't even
think that's why people move here right
I think those are like nice to haves uh
I think really the reason why people
move here is for the people and one of
the things that you'll find is if you
all walk out of this hotel and you go
walk down the street uh it feels like
all the benefits of America at the same
time with all of the great parts of
other parts of the world right and you
know the joke in Miami is that English
is not the native language uh which is
you know some people love some people
don't like that right um I tend to think
though that it has become this Melting
Pot and we're talking about someone
backstage and they were saying that
Miami is the second largest home in
America behind New York for French
people
it's the second largest home in America
for Italians
and then obviously you have kind of
Miami being the capital of Latin America
right and and kind of the joke there and
so when you look at this it's people
ultimately I believe want three things
they want a place where they feel safe
they want a place where they feel like
their government wants them to be
successful and they want a place where
they feel like there is true economic
Mobility that if they do the right
things and they work hard they can
ultimately grow a life of wealth and
there's no guarantee of that and I think
that in Miami one of the things I love
is that any time that there is even the
hint of an idea of a socialist idea
there's a bunch of people say nope I've
seen this Playbook we do not want that
like that is not going to happen here
and so
um when when you just say to yourself
like what is America America is a
democratic capitalistic Society uh and I
think that there's a lot of people who
really want to embrace that and a good
portion of those people are still moving
to Miami and
there we go well said
because Suarez is going to take that
including there and like run that as an
ad he told me to ask you so there you go
but uh no all jokes aside uh pom very
big thank you really appreciate you
joining us today and before we head off
stage any parting words again we are in
this change this phase change of the
industry of web3 a lot of things are
very shaky as you said you know people
are waking up in the morning probably
questioning people are probably getting
a lot of questions from the family why
are you leaving a good corporate job to
go into this industry Etc any parting
words of wisdom or any kind of
encouragement as we look at this change
and decide to continue on in this
industry
I've been saying this for a long time
but I I think one aspect
um during the good times that gets lost
is that like it's all of your
responsibility each and every single one
of you like what did you do to help push
this forward some of you are great at
software go build software some of you
are great at marketing go do marketing
some of you are great at legal and
Regulatory stuff go do that like
whatever your unique skill set is
whatever you're personally interested in
I think you have to ask yourself like
what am I doing personally to push this
forward and the beauty of a
decentralized kind of uncoordinated
system is that if every single person
just does the thing that they're good at
doing the overall system ends up getting
pushed forward and benefiting and we've
seen that with Bitcoin in a very unique
way and I think that the rest of the
industry is starting to figure that out
as well of just like what can you do and
how much or how often can you do it and
if you just take that as personal
responsibility I tend to think that the
whole will be better off for it
one supporter out there all right
perfect Anthony pompliano thank you very
very much thank you